as an American I am proud to call myself
an expert connoisseur of the K of the
Pops but as the lame will call it the
pumps oops we're gonna watch from the
group 17 a music video from their song
fear in Korean it's pronounced like the
text that's on screen right now this is
a top war - request from one of our
lovely patrons Laura Moore Thank You
Laura see we've covered a lot of BTS and
she wants us to branch out into all the
k-pop groups and I said yeah I don't
even need the homework I know all these
lyrics by heart mm-hmm definitely get
ready for a sing-along oh that's the
best kind of reaction put this in a
movie theater you know guys over on our
patreon we do music video reactions as
well I mean we've done BTS on one
channel but if you want some more uncut
content come check us out over there the
hell are you I don't know I'm suffering
from hallucinations
whoa
[Music]
failure
there's so many people yeah
thirteen members oh man dude all of them
feel like they're toxic no flip it under
Wow cool what do you like beat them
think all you guys need therapy if this
is the case oh no don't be afraid
surrounded heartbreaking song for
something stupid I know such a banger oh
[Music]
god yes I'm talking about Oh God
you are poison dude you're like an
alcohol addiction waiting to happen man
yeah
[Music]
I think you need a like apologize to
your parents or make up with them they
might have really caused you a lot of
trouble my love song at all Oh
[Music]
I kind of love it if oh no they actually
you know got a lot of women or men of
hymns and one of them has to be gay it's
a lot of guys it's just the odds I'm not
accusing anyone singularly like if that
person's gay and I'm just saying like
you know it doesn't matter it doesn't
even matter if I'm involved in reggae
why are you making it about the game I'm
sorry I write it like you're trying to
cover your ass you're trying not to
offend stop it John I'm just
overcompensating they stop it okay stop
it really should I love the idea of them
doing this song talking about how they
are toxic and relationships but because
the song is so engaging and there's such
good singers and dancers that women fall
in love with them or men and they get
into a relationship and they end up
being that way and then they could I
told you yeah the very first time we met
all 20 of us said we're toxic people to
be in a relationship with so this is all
on you I gave you a heads up I gave the
world yes five million people heard us
say it alright so back on your excuses
yeah that's what this is just one big
red flag I love the irony of songs like
this when I'm driving yeah but when you
listen to the lyrics like guys
they sound like really terrible people
like yeah this is a very love Lauren
heartbroken he's just lying cuz he
doesn't know how to break it out like
this is an anguished song they're
talking about codependent toxicity
relationships also sounds like a lot of
narcissistic abuse I just kept thinking
about it it's psychology this is the new
crux of our channel this is like go
analyzing yeah that's what I'll do man I
mean I got to provide something yes
that's perfect you know you talk about
beats and all that you talk about all
the great things that happen I'll talk
about this from the most realistic
statement possible to provide my
commentary on oh yeah hey they're a
great group them I love the beat I
really did
he had the beat
[Laughter]
I know everybody that is what is it oh
it's Sam Tonio Ben Darras but what's it
called and like step by step except to
the plate over here to step to step what
was that movie I know I can see the
trailer it's a good night via the beat a
strains high school students on how to
be better - it's like pick up your feet
or some like random title like that
comment below yeah Korean people love
they that's how these guys I'll learn to
dampen watching Antoniou teach
underprivileged students I thought the
way the music video was done the colors
and all it was beautiful everything was
great I had a hard time seeing past the
lyrics just like it sounds like you had
a lot of abuse from your parents and now
you're taking down your significant
others forever that's the interesting
thing to me about this song is I feel
like if you just played the music and no
lyrics and you just watch the video I'm
not sure I would have caught the meaning
of the song I would have thought it was
some kind of braggadocious up-tempo like
confident banger so the contrast is kind
of fascinating to me the music video
it's Celt like other than the car
wreckage I didn't feel like the visuals
hinted at what was going on in the music
I feel like we've seen some other videos
in this vein that match a little bit
better - like what the song is about not
to say that the production values
weren't incredible it's beautiful to
look at I liked a lot of the lighting I
liked the video component but at the
same time I don't know if I would have
linked it if I didn't know the words but
I respect that though I love those kind
of songs where like the feeling the song
provide because music is how would I put
it it'd be sound sure I'll go with the
emotion of music is all communicated
through the harmony through the sound
and the tune of it all not so much the
lyrics like I always look at lyrics
though that's that's my main thing I pay
attention to but a lot of songs that I
end up loving just because you know
you're feeling it will you take time to
like deconstruct what they're saying you
go oh really dark stuff actually now
it's kind of the vibe I got with this
one but well it's therapy though it's
pretty fascinating because it's pretty
honest kind of song when you think about
yeah like very straightforward that is a
real thing their situation yeah yeah I
mean I can identify in a lot of ways too
in my past of how I've been I've got a
lot of damage within a lot of toxicity
within that I haven't resolved and now
it's coming out at me in on a
relationship and I think a lot of people
can relate with that so it's pretty cool
that you've actually got to me here it's
multi-layered and I do appreciate yeah
that's sort of subtle irony that happens
when the tone of a song and the lyrical
content kind of not clash but contrasts
from one another I do think that that's
an interesting way to orchestrate music
and I mean the song itself like the
backing instrumental I thought was
pretty dynamic and hit hard like I don't
know if those were actually guitars but
they were part of this that reminded me
kind of something bordering on like pop
rock or something like that and then you
know you go into the verses and there's
a little bit more of that airy since
stuff it just had like a lot of Drive
and a kind of dark overall Sheen to the
sound of the song especially in that way
I feel like the sound the tone beyond
how like again banger II and like damn
you easily dance to this in a club the
darkness of the sound does compliment
the subject matter pretty nicely and
yeah just the way the words come
together at least in the translation is
very lucid and very again like forward
and well formed gotta watch more 17 I
say I know I know they got like three
rappers and for singers and eight
dancers and you know a bunch of other
people I don't know I read a breakdown
and I forgot the numbers they're
supposed to be the expert I am just
getting to know this do you know how
long it took me to learn the seven
members of bangtan bang alright guys
well you can subscribe quick bells like
this video hit us up on patreon for more
music videos yup Laura thank you so much
you
have been an incredible support to us
recently we had to announce that we are
stopping the topper war tears at our
patreon page come February and Laura was
very understanding so much so that she
quadrupled her pledge instead and I was
like whoa Laura my whole point was to
let people know that because we're
stopping it you might want to lower your
pledge and she's like I'm gonna give
three times as much and I said Laura
please I I don't want to be like feeling
guilty about this I don't want to be put
in a position where you feel like you're
pledging so much but then we can't honor
that amount because there's nothing
there for that amount and she said no
I'm dying I want to give all my money to
you 125 that you would spend your last
living wage that's that's incredible
attention
maybe we should learn to be medical
people and then use that pledge money -
yeah where are you going I don't know I
said she was dying so I was like oh she
must be sick Laura doesn't open up to me
enough about her personal life that we
should make up a personal life for her I
just did what it was dying and
contributing a lot of money